TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello and welcome
to the "Developer Show."
I'm your host Timothy Jordan.
Let's start with a quick review
of what happened recently
with the Google
Developer platform,
also known as the TLDR.
Perform complex back
end logic on data
store in real time with
automatic synchronization
across devices-- Android
plus Firebase plus Google
App Engine makes it happen.
David East is here today to
explain it all a bit further.
DAVID EAST: That's me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Logs
just got a lot better
with Metrics Advanced
Filters and Charts brought
to you by Google Cloud Logging
and Google Cloud Monitoring,
available today in beta.
Improved navigation, search,
customization, and visibility
are available today in a
beta new design of the cloud
console.
Try it today and let
us know what you think.
Universal app campaigns and
user acquisition performance
reporting is now available in
Google Play Developer Console
to make ads and user
growth as simple as writing
an async task.
A recent Google Shopper
survey revealed that over 40%
of people are likely to use
their phones to pay digitally
for products this
holiday season.
Google's Head of commerce
Sridhar Ramaswamy
recently sat down with "Fortune"
to discuss this and more
commerce trends to come.
Joanna Smith is
on the show today
to discuss what this
means for us developers.
JOANNA SMITH: Money.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: As
the crow flies is not
the best measure of proximity.
But thanks to the
Distance Matrix Service
as part of the
Google Maps API, you
can calculate what
point of interest
is actually the closest
to travel for your users.
Get a Project Tango developer
kit for 50% off with a special
limited time offer on the
Google Store available soon,
and keep an eye out on the
Google+ community for an update
on the sale.
And in the meantime,
check out the recent app
contest winners for
some inspiration.
Links in the description below
with all the other links.
Record your game play
and share it on YouTube
from your phone with an
update to Google Play Games.
It includes support for your
front-facing camera and mic,
so we know how you really
feel about that hidden bomb.
Also, we're working
on an SDK for this,
so you can build it right
into your own app or game.
VR is cool.
Seriously, it's cool.
And Google Cardboard
now makes it
possible around the
world in 39 languages
and in more than 100 countries
on both Android and iOS-- oh,
and the SDK got updated too.
Fred Sauer is also cool
and on the show today
to tell us a little
more about Cardboard.
FRED SAUER: I'm super
excited to be here today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Turkish
mobile games developer
Peak Games has a growing
user base in the US
with their game Spades Plus.
The game generates over
70% of its mobile revenue
from Android.
We recently had a chat
with them about how
they improved user
engagement, increased installs
with Google Play Store listing
experiments and app promotion,
as well as other Android
and Google Play features
that help them be successful.
Here's a quick clip from the
video-- a peek, if you will,
at Peak Games.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Peak Games was founded in 2010.
Our aim is to create
global technology products
and reach millions of users.
We take the classic
game experience
and migrate it to mobile.
Additional to that, we
also build casual games.
Android is our priority
mobile platform.
Currently, we have 65K
open stores every day.
Most of our games are
dependent on scale,
and getting more
users in Android
is a lot easier than any
other mobile platform.
Android has been super
helpful in growing
international markets,
and that's where
we believe our future is lying.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
You can find a link
to the full video below
in the show notes below.
They're awesome.
Click on things.
Fred, Cardboard,
you have Cardboard.
Tell us about Cardboard, the
new release, and all that stuff.
FRED SAUER: OK so Cardboard,
obviously awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
FRED SAUER: But as a developer,
you want to build great apps.
So now we have a new SDK
that has some performance
improvements and gives
you better image quality.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Excellent.
And it has something to do with
the distortion and the lenses,
right?
FRED SAUER: Yeah,
so the distortion
that we have to put in
the image to compensate
for the lenses in there
is done more efficiently.
So we can give you more
pixels, higher quality images.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's just a recompile.
FRED SAUER: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
I love Cardboard.
Did I ever tell you
why I love Cardboard?
FRED SAUER: Why?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
sure I have, because I'm
a huge VR geek, which you know.
FRED SAUER: Tell me
your Cardboard story.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: They might
not know I'm a huge VR geek,
but the thing is, that when
I was first getting into VR,
it was so expensive.
I just couldn't see it.
It was prohibitive for--
FRED SAUER: Like
$10,000 for head--
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's right, and that
didn't even the include the
computer and all the software
and whatever.
But now--
FRED SAUER: It's not $10,000.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's $10,000.
FRED SAUER: It's the phone I
already have plus Cardboard
and two lenses.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
FRED SAUER: And a rubber band
to hold the phone in place.
JOANNA SMITH: That's
the part I like.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
What do you think
is next for developers
with Cardboard?
Like where is this going?
FRED SAUER: Really understanding
VR I think is important.
It's a different experience.
So we have an app in the App
Store called the Cardboard
Design Lab.
If you're doing
anything with Cardboard,
you've got to check it out.
It's best practices, and it
shows you what to do and what
not to do, like what makes
people sick and what doesn't.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's like
a whole new design skill set.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, because
this is so immersive.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
kind of important.
FRED SAUER: So you
know that sensation
if you're sitting in a train,
and then the train next to you
pulls away?
And just for a moment,
you think you're moving?
That can happen here too.
And that can make you sick.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
FRED SAUER: But if
you do it right,
you have a great experience.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So really learning
what makes a great VR
app and simple stuff
like not making people sick,
too, I imagine another best
practice.
FRED SAUER: And you have
to try it with Cardboard.
It's not the same as doing it
on your development machine.
You have to compile it,
run it, check it out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool, thank
you, appreciate those tips.
Let's jump over to Firebase
and Google App Engine.
So developers have been
working with Firebase
with their Android apps and
their iOS apps and so forth.
But this adds a new layer.
This is like a back end
intelligence to real time data.
DAVID EAST: Yeah, it's
funny talking about Firebase
on the back end of things
because most people are used
to using it on the front side.
But what's cool about
that is not everything
you can do from the phone,
because it's not always on,
so you can't always be
routinely sending emails,
or you can't send a push
notification from the phone.
So those type of
things you can use
Firebase for because you
spin it up on the server,
and it's not really like a
server, it's more of a client.
So I built a ton of apps,
and this is something
that I do quite frequently.
And when you spin up this like
smart client that you can trust
so you can put all of your keys
on there or your certificates,
and then that way,
it can send out
push notifications and
response to something
that happened in Firebase.
So now you have this client
that's sitting on a server,
and you have your phone,
and they're totally away
from each other.
But yet, at the same time,
they're in total harmony,
synchronizing the same data.
FRED SAUER: So you have a
robot client in the cloud?
JOANNA SMITH: A trusted robot.
DAVID EAST: A
trusted robot, yeah.
FRED SAUER: A butler.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Your most
trusted robot Jeeves.
DAVID EAST: Robot
butler as a service.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Butler
as a service, very good.
So that robot can also
do like Cron jobs, right?
It's not just
responding changes.
DAVID EAST: Yeah, Cron jobs
is one of the really cool use
cases because you
can essentially
set up a Cron job that sends
out like your newsletter email.
So every whatever
days or every day,
you can send out the daily
push to all of your users,
and that's a simple Cron job.
It queries the database, grabs
the data, and sends it out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
JOANNA SMITH: So it's a
motivated trusted robot?
DAVID EAST: Yes.
FRED SAUER: I want
a robot butler.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, Joanna,
let's talk about money.
JOANNA SMITH: Well, specifically
let's talk about shopping
and how we can spend the money,
like on our robot butlers,
right?
FRED SAUER: I would
buy one right now.
JOANNA SMITH:
Right, well, that's
why we make money, right?
To like spend it on things?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And robot butlers.
JOANNA SMITH: So
specifically, I think
that Android Pay is going
to exciting for our holiday
season.
We can all kind of
agree that that's
going to change a lot
of in-store experiences.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
making things a lot easier.
JOANNA SMITH: So much easier.
But the thing is
developers aren't really
looking at that because it
doesn't really affects them,
and I think that's
kind of a mistake.
That article was so
great and Sridhar
said something that
really resonated
with me, which is that shopping
moments are replacing shopping
marathons.
FRED SAUER: What does
that mean exactly?
JOANNA SMITH: So, if you
think about it, normally,
you don't spend all
day on Saturday running
all of your errands,
going to each store
that you need something from.
In fact, you probably don't
buy three things in one day
anymore.
You realize that you're out
of toothpaste, you order
more toothpaste online, right?
Or you're browsing like some
interesting clothes online,
you impulse buy whichever
looks most interesting.
FRED SAUER: I think I agree.
We used to do those marathons,
like weekend was shopping.
Or I'm from Holland.
My town was Thursday
evenings were shop.
JOANNA SMITH: Everybody
would go, right?
FRED SAUER: The
whole town would go.
JOANNA SMITH: We
buy as we need now.
We don't save it up
in a list anymore.
And I think that if developers
aren't building that
into their app, if they're
not creating shopping moments,
they're really missing out on a
golden opportunity to monetize.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Facilitating shopping,
like I think one
of things that I do
is I don't keep a
list of books that I'm
going to read any more.
I just buy them digitally
right away, right?
And then I have a
stack of virtual books.
If I know I'm going
to read the book,
I might as well get
it now, and then it's
waiting for me when
I have the time.
FRED SAUER: So if I recommend
a robot butler book to you,
you'd buy it right now.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What is
it with the robot butler?
Yes.
JOANNA SMITH: Do you
have a robot butler?
FRED SAUER: No, I
said I want one.
DAVID EAST: We're
working on it, all right?
FRED SAUER: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, let's go
to our last clip of the show,
and that's all
about patent trolls.
They're lurking out
there just waiting
to tear down your business.
And our Senior Policy
Correspondent Derek Slater
wants to make sure you know
how to protect yourself
from these strange beasts.
But first, we asked some of
Google's Student Ambassadors
to give their best guess
at what patent trolls are.
Have a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I think a patent
troll is probably
someone who just comes up
with just random things
and just patents them.
-And so basically
they're using that patent
to try and litigate, extracts
some fees, settle out of court,
and I think they
impede progress a lot.
-It prevents you
from doing it better
because of that little
nasty patent they have.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
was really good.
DEREK SLATER: It
was pretty good.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: But I know
you can tie it together
for us-- put a bow on this.
What is a patent troll?
DEREK SLATER: Yes, so
they were pretty close.
Patents are supposed to
encourage innovation.
What patent trolls do is
they don't invent anything.
They come up with
some broad idea
that they get a patent
for, and then they
go around threatening
to sue people.
Let me tell you a little
story to make that clearer.
This guy David Bloom was working
at a Fortune 500 company,
leaves to become
an app developer,
to start a company called
Ordrx, where restaurants
can share their menus,
make it easy to be
ordered from any app.
Raises millions of dollars in
VC funding, has 20 employees,
is going along great.
And then this patent troll
comes along who says,
I am the inventor.
I own a patent on sharing
menus, and he sues David Bloom.
David Bloom tries to
fight it, but he loses
clients, who get scared off.
He loses investors
who get scared off.
And earlier this year had
to go out of business.
That's a story unfortunately
of too many app developers
and small businesses.
It can cost like $1 million
at least to defend yourself,
and it's happened to people
who create podcasts, like Marc
Maron and Adam Carolla.
It's happened to people who
do online test software.
It's happened to people
just running Wi-Fi routers.
Last year there were nearly
3,000 patent troll lawsuits.
That's up 500% over
the last decade.
This is a growing problem.
There are more people like
David Bloom every year.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is crazy.
They're able to get away with
this time and time again.
Obviously, there's a growing
industry of patent trolls.
What can we do to fix this?
DEREK SLATER: So we need
a better system in place
for having quality
patents to be issued.
There needs to be deterrence
built in the system
so that there's some
penalty if you go and file
one of these frivolous lawsuits
using one of these bad patents.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, what else?
DEREK SLATER: The main
thing that people can do
is they can go and tell
Congress to fix it.
That's really where the
fix needs to happen.
Fortunately, in the
House and the Senate
there are two bills right
now, the Innovation Act
and the Patent Act.
If you go to fixpatents.org,
you can go and tell
your Congress person, your
senator to go and pass those,
and hopefully that
will happen soon.
Those bills, among other
things, would make it
so that if a patent troll
files a lawsuit and they lose,
they have to pay the other
side's attorneys fees.
That would be a good
amount of deterrence
from just going after and
threatening random people.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
All right-- 500%?
DEREK SLATER: 500%, and
over the last 20 years,
that's about a half
trillion dollars of damage
to the US economy.
Last five years, about
$8 billion in lost VC
funding due to patent trolls.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right
so go to this website.
DEREK SLATER: Fixpatents.org.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks for
coming on the show, Derek.
DEREK SLATER: Pleasure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's been our show.
To say goodbye to the panel,
I'd like to ask them a question.
What absurd patents are you
going to invent-- or patent,
I suppose-- in 2016?
DAVID EAST: So I really want
to make an API that tells you
when you're hungry
because like I drink
an ungodly amount of
caffeine every day,
so I don't always actually
know when I'm truly hungry.
So I'd like to be able
to build an app that
detects when I'm hungry,
then orders me food, and then
just when it arrives, I'm
like, oh, my gosh, I am hungry.
Thank you, robot butler app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Actually sounds
really useful for coding days.
FRED SAUER: I would
use those APIs.
JOANNA SMITH: Should file that
before we release this video.
DAVID EAST: That's a good idea.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, Joanna?
JOANNA SMITH: I'm
going to patent
the notion of fingernails
that grow in length over time
and need to be reduced.
I'm going to make money every
you guys trim your nails.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Fred?
FRED SAUER: I want to
patent pockets with holes.
Two reasons-- so when
you go to the beach,
you don't get sand
caught in your pockets.
And then when you put your
clothes in the laundry,
you don't accidentally
leave stuff in there
that goes through the laundry.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Pockets where
nothing gets stuck in them.
FRED SAUER: Yep.
JOANNA SMITH: But what about
the holding purpose of a pocket?
FRED SAUER: Oh, no,
that's irrelevant.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
DAVID EAST: I'm going to
owe you a lot of money.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Why
would you owe him money?
DAVID EAST: Because I've got
a lot holes in my pockets.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
so please tell us
about your absurd patent
ideas down in the comments,
or really any other ideas
you have about the show
or what we've talked
about, and we'll
be sure to respond to you.
Thanks for joining us this week,
and I'll see you next time.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and this
has been the "Developer Show."